[Music]
hello and welcome to trevor phillips on
sunday
it's easy to forget in the political hue
and cry what this is really all about
the toll of covert deaths is now closing
in on 150
150
000 the entire population of blackpool
and alongside the many families who have
suffered bereavement
millions have endured the pain of not
being able to comfort a loved one during
lockdown
that's why i guess a nation which is
usually slow to anger seems suffused
with rage this morning
the very people who urged us to be
responsible and to sacrifice for the
good of the nation
seem to have shown no such restraint
themselves
instead they partied
and worse when they were called out it
appears that they were ready to tell us
anything except the truth
and for once the post watergate cliche
may be appazite it's not the crime that
gets you it's the cover-up
this morning as omicron threatens to
turn back the clock on the fight against
coronavirus we'll ask if plan b will
work and explore with our guests what
all this means for boris johnson and his
administration
in a moment i'll speak to the man who
has the unenviable task of defending his
boss the prime minister after a
horrendously damaging week for the
government that's education secretary
nadim zahawi also able to give us an
important update on where we are on
omicron given his former job as vaccines
minister
conservative mps are restless given the
polish state of number 10 and sin and
its inhabitants reputation right now
let's talk about major revolt over the
new coveted restrictions and even rumors
about the beginning of the end of the
boris johnson era
i'll talk to the influential backbencher
steve baker
we'll get labour's take on things from
the party chair annalisa dodge
and we'll get an all-important update
from johannesburg with all eyes on the
data coming from south africa as we try
to work out just how dangerous omicron
will be in the uk
i'll talk to government advisor barry
schube
so we'll find out what it might mean for
the uk and get a sense of the state of
covid in scotland from infectious
diseases uh expert debbie bogart from
the university of edinburgh
and we'll also talk about the impact of
covet on education following the
disturbing new research that shows young
people from the north are particularly
hard-hit i'm talking to york university
professor kate pickett
but first i'm joined by the secretary of
state for education nadim zahabi good
morning mr zahali good morning travis
can we start with the numbers please how
many people
uh are do we know are infected by
omicron and how many are being
hospitalized at this moment
so what we know um hence the concern is
that one third of infections now in
london are omicron
we think uh that obviously the reported
tests
uh are indicating about uh 1 600 cases
but of course the number of infections
in the community would be a multiple of
that up to 10 times
that we know that it uh
um is highly infectious so the doubling
rate is between two and three days
so uh very quickly omicron uh will be
get
be the dominant uh variant in the united
kingdom and probably the rest of the
world we've seen this movie before we
saw it with kent variant then of course
delta
one of the obviously advantages we have
is we've got a very large capacity for
testing and of course genome sequencing
hence why we know so much we also know
um and i can confirm to you this morning
that there are cases in hospital
with omicron
we've been able to uh test people who
are in hospitals over the past two weeks
and so there is a lag to hospitalization
but the risk of a highly infectious
variant even if it were
as many people
quite rightly think because some of the
data from south africa suggesting that
it is less
severe
even if that is true well if you get to
one million infections because you know
you understand exponential growth
so if you know
by the end of the month you're at a
million with three days later you're at
two million
and if it's um half as severe as delta
let's say only one percent end up with
serious infection and hospitalization
that's still ten thousand people still a
big number it's a huge number you were
the vaccines minister and the government
uh to be honest has
played a great deal on your success on
the rollout and pinned its strategy
entirely on the successful vaccine what
do we know about the impact of the
vaccines
uh first second
and booster jab on omicron so you're
absolutely right we've answered the
first question is it more infectious yes
the second question do the vaccines work
well we know now
and some data was published over the
last uh
48 hours
that
two doses of either pfizer or astrogenic
are not enough they only protect to
about 30 percent acidic even less than
that but a booster does raise that
protection back up to where we were when
we got to equilibrium
between vaccine efficacy and delta
and we need to get back to that so this
is going to be a national endeavor we
need to vaccinate with a third jab the
booster jab so important all those
people who become eligible all adults
because it is now a race
between the booster and that protection
and the omicron variant well you've
already said made the point exponential
growth
is
can be astonishing
uh
what are you going to do
to
boost the
spread of the the
booster jab as it were we can't
presumably carry on with the same uh
process as we had before we discovered
omicron that's that the the
administration of boosters is going to
have to be accelerated pretty
dramatically what's a plan
so there is absolutely uh a plan and the
prime minister will be saying more on
this um
you will know that the nhs is already um
uh making preparations from monday for
the
30s uh the 30 year old to be able to
come forward um after their second job
after you know 90 days so three months
after your second job to get your
booster um we are mobilizing um
the um the the old team the um
frontline we have gps community
pharmacies uh military
across the board volunteers we're asking
people to come forward and volunteer uh
you can go on and join the volunteering
army on the national volunteering
service website it's really important
this is a race genuinely i say you can
you can increase the number of people
who are putting uh
jabs in on but what are you doing about
providing more access essentially you
move up to whatever it is 16 million or
something like that in the boosted
presumably you've got to get
into the 30 millions of 40 millions
very very fast yeah so we're over 20
million already um
and you're absolutely right it is now a
race to get
all adults who are eligible
for their boosted jabs to be boosted as
quickly as possible and the prime
minister will be saying more about this
uh later today all right look um the
other side of this is what the prime
minister's been saying that you are
imposing restrictions in order to slow
the spread and give us time
um on tuesday the deputy prime minister
was saying that there were no further
coronavirus restrictions required uh
beyond what you'd said last weekend and
the former prime minister theresa may
was cheered by tori and peace when she
said we've got to learn to live with
covet now within 24 hours situations
turn
completely and there are going to be new
restrictions first of all what is it
that happened in that 24 hours
so let me just be clear
as patrick valance said at the press
conference we are
transitioning this virus from pandemic
to endemic but there are
you know big bumps in the road and this
is a big bump a huge bump in the road in
the sense that we now have a
a variant
that is so infectious
that it will um dominate and of course
exponentially grow so back to what we're
talking about so let's do a mathematical
exercise for a second
right you get to a million um infections
by say end of december right
one percent is 10 000 severe infections
that could be in hospital three days
later it's two million right three days
later it's four million right three days
beyond that it's eight million right
that is the the risk that even if it's
milder say by 50
milder than delta
the numbers are huge it's a small
percentage of a very large population
that is the big difference
so the reason we're taking these
proportionate
i think precautionary measures
the most significant of is by the way
that scientists
tell us is the work from home
that will have the greatest impact on
slowing down omicron um so hence why
we've had to take these measures i think
they are proportionate they're
precautionary the really important thing
is for the whole nation it's going to be
a national endeavor at trevor right a
national endeavor to to
boost the nation as quickly as possible
so that we control omicron and bring
back that equilibrium that we had with
the virus as we continue to protect the
economy and of course on that journey
towards um endemic from pandemic status
is the move to vaccinate primary school
children part of this
race against the spread of omicron so
there's no plan at the moment
to vaccinate primary schools for the
reason that the joint committee on
vaccination immunization is still
looking at the uh uh evidence as to what
level of protection that would offer
those uh children of course um we
vaccinate the
12 to 15 year olds at pace it's great to
see you know at school in east london
the other day doing uh uh
the pupils but also managed to do some
of the teachers and parents who hadn't
even had their first
or second job really good we're seeing
it all over you know home park in
plymouth doing staying up to 2am
vaccinating people so the important
thing is to boost the most vulnerable
that is absolutely the priority but but
surely the important thing is all the
the most important thing given what you
said about the terrifying spread and all
the rest of it is to stop the spread of
the infection and sage scientists have
warned that the children
were the drivers of adult infection in
the summer wave last year so surely we
need to do something about that so
really excellent question which is why
we obviously
um
begun as soon as we had permission from
the jcvi to vaccinate 12 15 year olds
because you saw a spike in uh secondary
schools on that
the if you think about exponential
growth which you and i just talked about
this is so infectious the best way to
slow it down is
to keep you know people working from
home for example keep adults apart
but at the same time is just protecting
the economy hence why it's proportionate
we've tried to do everything in these
new measures to keep the economy open
keep it running protect businesses
because
that also does you know a lot of harm to
people's health mental health as well as
physical health
the important thing is you want to
protect the most vulnerable because you
know that ultimately even if it's less
severe it will put the most vulnerable
okay but surely uh one other thing that
you ought to be thinking about here is
mandatory vaccination
i don't agree with that and i tell you
for why um we have very high levels of
vaccine positivity in the uk probably
highest in the world
all the data suggests that whether it's
the ons or other surveys you know 90
plus percent of all adults say um
they've looked at the information
they're protecting themselves protecting
the communities protecting their loved
ones um so to um
now play into the hands of the
anti-vaxxers uh by the way i understand
people who are hesitant and it's right
that we focus and give them information
but the anti-vaxxers will will say ah
you see that's why they're they're
they're they're now doing this stuff
actually the right thing to do is share
information
and okay have this national endeavor now
to really protect it is a race trevor
and we've got to now drive hard for the
next couple of weeks to protect the most
vulnerable all right well look the um
success of that national endeavor
depends to a large extent on the
leadership of the government so let's
talk about leadership
18 months ago dominic cummings barnard
castle 12 months ago prime minister's
aides uh partying and prime minister
himself uh by the way who knows how many
christmas parties one two three prime
minister himself hosting a quiz night
everybody's breaking the rules that you
set for the rest of us so let me repeat
what i said to one of your cabinet
colleagues earlier on this year
why
when you tell us
to show restraint
to be part of this national endeavor
should we pay the blindest bit of
attention to you guys
so
the first to say on that is that
actually the nation
has uh been brilliant at following the
guidelines
before they knew what you guys had been
up to all the time even yesterday people
were queuing up at vaccination sites
walking sites or booking uh their uh
booster jab that's a great thing and i
am
grateful to to people doing that and we
thank them for that
on parties the cabinet secretary has an
investigation and his investigation can
take him anywhere to look at all parties
i have to say to you you just mentioned
the quiz night and that picture today
what do we see in that picture we see a
prime minister on a virtual uh quiz
night for 10 to 15 minutes to thank his
staff who by the way had no choice but
to come in
every single day let me just finish let
me just finish this point right sitting
in his office with the two people who
are closest working with him no alcohol
on the table not drinking right on a
zoom call or a team's call on virtual
call respecting the the lockdown rules
many people would have had similar zoom
quiz nights around the country yeah and
they would have been nicked for it if i
had done it no if i had done it hold on
i would be in monster trouble but
because you went on a virtually get to
do it because you went on a virtual uh
he was sitting next to two people
within social distance they are in his
office they work with him and that was
the point was that no hold on a second
when you when all i'm saying to you is
the cabinet secretary is going to
investigate everything but that picture
i'm in many ways i've had emails from
constituents because the hype around
parties that was going on in the last
week and the week before right made it
sound sort of completely different and
actually i think people will look at
that picture today and the daily mirror
has been leading the way on this and
we'll think hold on a second he's on a
virtual call no alcohol that's not
thanking his staff for 10 minutes before
he goes back to this
is that
is that really let's not get too stuck
on the one photograph let us remember
how this issue started over the last two
weeks it started
with the allegation that there were
parties and several days
of the prime minister and other
government spokespeople saying oh no
there were no parties
that's the problem isn't it it's not
that oh something might have happened
that could have happened in any office
it was that we
when when the government was asked did
this happen
we were told point blank they didn't
happen until you had to admit they did
have in your own department
you you fessed up straight away so let
me let me talk about my department and
then talk about uh your your question on
your question the prime minister said to
the best of his knowledge um there were
no parties
he didn't attend any parties
he also said that the rules were
followed and you saw that in the picture
today it's a virtual zoom
call
not you know anything else and i think
the nation will understand that now
because the hype around it was these
parties you know where people were were
mixing and and lots of drinks was were
flowing um is not there as far as my
department when you say the hype around
it are you saying they didn't no i'm
just saying you're not coming in you're
telling me i'm not i am not i'm saying
that the cabinet secretary will
investigate all those allegations he can
go anywhere with his investigation and
that will happen he'll report
rapidly on this as far as my department
when i found out
that there was a gathering
where people came together in the
canteen who'd been working in the office
because they couldn't work from home
where the previous secretary of state
wanted to thank them then we apologize
because actually upon reflection in
hindsight it shouldn't have happened um
but it's the right thing to do is to
come out and say look this is what
happened people working at their desk
they brought their own drinking again
but we're sitting at their desk but then
it was felt it's better to go to the
canteen to maintain self-distancing to
thank them
for this this is exactly my point
you did that
by contrast to your boss and my question
to you really i mean we've known each
other for some time
my question to you is
do you feel any sense of shame that you
have to sit at a cabinet table with
people who seem willing to say anything
and do anything other than to admit the
truth as you did within 24 hours so the
again i'm going to repeat the cabinet
secretary will look at any allegation
his investigator can go anywhere and
he'll report back and then i will come
back on this program and be answerable
for that report but let's step back a
second right i feel very proud that this
prime minister actually set up the
vaccines task force bought 400 million
plus vaccines for the nation we've got
enough supply for the booster which we
now know and if you hadn't made a
decision to spend the money on the
additional fisa
doses we would not have the booster
campaign today but let's i feel very
proud we're the first country to open up
and to maintain that opening of the
economy kirstama wanted us not to open
the economy imagine the damage that
would have done to people's lives i'm
going to let you say all of that but
let's let's be honest with each other
all of that may be true
but he has essentially
squandered that credit
because now
when he asks people to do things
the doubt about whether we can trust his
word is immense surely even you must
admit this is not irrespective of the
politics of it and all that this is
getting in the way
of tackling that terrifying threat that
you've described earlier in this
interview we need to move fast and every
day the people cannot trust the prime
minister
it's costing lives you must see that
well
as i was saying to you earlier actually
if you look at the evidence people have
been very good at understanding how to
protect themselves their family and
their community they've been very good
at following the rules hence why we were
able to reopen the economy and do it so
successfully we're now asking them again
to be cautious to be careful um
proportionately and to try and and to
race towards the booster well to to to
trust their government that managed to
deliver the most successful vaccination
program in history and of course reopen
the economy so rapidly and by the way
spend 407 billion protecting jobs and
livelihoods all right one last let me
give this one last go they sent you out
this morning with a brief frankly to
defend the indefensible
is it time to admit the prime minister
who you've supported all along uh
in i think the most
honest and open way is it time to admit
that
you supported him in part because he's
an election winner but he's now becoming
a liability i don't agree with that i
work very closely with boris johnson i
worked with him um when i was business
and industry minister with the vaccines
task force and then when he asked me to
do the
vaccination deployment program he works
literally all hours to make sure we get
through this pandemic
the number of decisions i've seen him
make including making sure we had enough
vaccine making sure we have this the
fastest vaccine deployment program and
he will make sure again that the booster
campaign is going to be a national
endeavor he is he is doing a serious job
at a serious time for the nation and
actually
if you look at the hype that's been
going on for two weeks around parties
i'd reverse the question and say you
know let's are the media you said
earlier before we went on air you know
little things keep us busy in the media
right
are you really getting the right balance
here in terms of
in terms of you know omicron is such an
important variance
versus versus talking about a zoom call
um where he's where he was motivating
his team so we had to work every day
without having you know they can't have
the ability to work from hope i've been
counting we spent the first 50 or 60 of
this interview talking about omicron you
did so we're not i'm not burying you
with trivia look
let's deal with something that could be
real
you could be back in here next sunday
after a conservative defeat
in the by-election at north shropshire
are you still going to be telling me in
that situation that boris johnson is the
right leader
in north shropshire no
after
is a doctor who's been vaccinating
people himself
he is
an
incredible asset uh to
the the political um landscape in the
united kingdom and i am confident
that the people of north shropshire will
see that and will actually support neil
shasta rehearse on thursday and he'll be
returned as our next time
and if he doesn't i will be back on your
program but i am confident that actually
when you look at what neil chaston's
hearst has done in his life okay he is
an excellent member of parliament for
north shropshire and boris johnson still
be boris johnson leader will will be
focusing on that national endeavor to
boost the nation it's a race against
time
minister secretary of state i should say
thank you very much indeed thank you
now i am filled uh with sorrow to see us
squandering trust the conservative party
is in the wrong place not me but
withering criticism from one of its own
and one of its most influential
backbenchers that is steve baker the
leading brexiteer and vice chair of the
group of conservative mps who are
skeptical of covid restrictions he joins
me now
good morning mr baker next tuesday the
house commons is going to vote on a new
set of measures to restrict the spread
of covert we've just been hearing from
the secretary of state are you going to
support your government
well i'm expecting four votes i will
vote against vaccine passports i'll vote
against extending a face mask mandate or
vote against mandatory vaccination as a
condition of nhs employment the fourth
one is a slightly liberalizing measure i
don't expect the house to divide but yes
i will vote against i think what we're
doing now is creating a miserable
dystopia that into which we're going
forward and that's why today i'm
announcing that i'll be relaunching
conservative way forward we need to
create a movement which actually says
the conservative party needs to be what
people traditionally have recognized as
conservative that is in favor of freedom
and personal responsibility so i hope
people will go to
conservativewayforward.com
and sign up as supporters and they'll be
the first to hear more
presumably you wouldn't be launching
this if you didn't have some support
do you have any idea how many members of
parliament will join you uh from the
conservative benches in voting against
the government on tuesday
well the spectator has run a list on
this and they've got 65 names on there
it's not absolutely clear to me that
they'll all vote against some may
abstain but i know about half a dozen
extra names so it feels to me that it's
going to be at least 60 people voting
against but of course it's a foregone
conclusion because our useless
opposition in name only will continue to
support the government however
authoritarian they are but you know
really this is a moment where every last
one of us should in good faith start
thinking about what it means with to
live with coronavirus like we live with
flu now that we're vaccinated and what
kind of society we want to live in in
the future i want one which is free
which is prosperous and which is joyful
in which young people can have a hope of
a better future and at the moment when
we're not looking like we're going to
deliver that if we keep on panicking
every time we get a variant this disease
will now be with us forever there will
be new variants the vaccine continues to
give a high degree of protection against
serious illness and death and in trade
we just do now need to get on with our
lives
uh we read this morning in the
newspapers uh about dissent in the
cabinet and the possibility that uh
ministers may resign what do you know
about that do you anticipate ministerial
resignations over
these measures
well i i don't know i mean so far
ministers have voted for a great many
things that they don't like doing and
that's been one of the hallmarks of this
period of the coronavirus you know we
keep doing that which we hate but saying
we'd like to be doing something else
well i'm afraid sooner or later if we're
going to save the soul of the
conservative party we've got to actually
do those things which we love to do and
that means being courageous and
temperate and prudent and think counting
the cost of lockdowns and restrictions
rather than having this endless tunnel
vision just on the disease you know we
we actually can't go on like this uh
only the conservative party can provide
good quality government that that draws
on the tradition of freedom and
responsibility under the rule of law and
all the time we have minute and
frequently changing rules governing our
lives so that we can't plan forward
whether it's for business or for
pleasure i'm afraid we're going to make
enormous swathes of our economy
uninvestable and they'll be just the
swathes which give our lives meaning
things like being able to go on holiday
being able to go to hospitality venues
you know we saw for a long time that
weddings were in trouble you know these
things really matter in our lives and
pretty soon we're going to start have to
start learning why it is that we've
always believed in this country that
freedom under the rule of law mattered
and that's really why i'm re-launching
conservative way forward we've got to
show that there is a movement for that
frame of mind because if we don't the
conservative party will continue to
drift into authoritarianism and i simply
cannot stand idly by while that happens
you um
you referred in a newspaper article this
morning to uh the conservative party
essentially and you've repeated it here
having lost its soul is that
what the johnston administration is
doing burying
the conservative uh soul as you
understand it
well at the moment we're in a pretty bad
shape you know boris did promise us that
he'd be as he put it a brexitee hezer
and that is what he's done he's a highly
interventionist prime minister i think
we did expect that he had two really
important jobs to do he had to take us
out of the european union albeit with
the unfinished business of the northern
ireland protocol and he had to make sure
he beat jeremy corbyn but i'm afraid i
did expect him to spend quite a lot of
money but i think that the thing that's
really changed now is we've used so much
quantitative easing that is money
creation to cover the enormous amount of
borrowing the government has had to get
us through covid i think now as we go
forward we've got to be extremely
careful to apply conservative principles
to what we do because the size of the
state the size of taxation is now not
consistent with conservative government
it's a it would be you know fit for a
miliband government and much as i'm on
friendly terms with ed miliband i didn't
want to be in his party mr baker what
what's interesting about the way you
talk about this is that um
you're not talking about it really
as a partisan or even an economic
question
you seem to be posing
the issue as a moral one and that in
some way where the conservative party is
now
is in some sense immoral uh in a sense
almost ethical or religious is that your
belief
well if i were to to put it to you as
plainly as i can surely life for each of
us is a process of becoming it's a
process of becoming greater tomorrow
than we were today not of comparing
ourselves to other people but comparing
ourselves to what we were and trying to
become better in some sense now if life
is a process of becoming don't we
deserve the dignity of choice as free
human beings with something like a soul
and if you don't have any kind of
spiritual belief well at least come up
with something which gives you meaning
as a freely choosing individual i mean
where are we going to find meaning and
purpose in our lives if we don't have
choice and responsibility and this
opportunity to grow and so that's why
i'm so very concerned that what is
happening here is we're being treated by
the government by the public health
establishment as automata who can't
manage to decide for themselves that
it's a good idea to wear a mask in an
enclosed space i think we've all learned
that now i'm certainly capable of doing
it freely and i'm very sure that your
viewers are capable of doing it too and
really we do need to think very
carefully now about what we wish to
become you know in society are our
relationships healthy when they're
voluntary or do they all need to be
coerced i mean this is a fundamental
question
i the reason i um
frame this or raise this as a moral
question is
partly as you said it's to do with
the question of individual choice but
morality also relates to leadership and
i want to ask you
about the leadership that you have
supported of your party and of the
government that you've supported
boris johnson this week um essentially
has been in a whole series of issues
about whether he has told us the whole
truth about payments for uh decoration
flats the issue of the again once again
of christmas parties and so on
do you think
that
this leadership
uh remains the sort of if i like could
put it this way moral leadership that
you can continue to support or does this
prime minister has this prime minister
reach the end of the road for you
well i'm really clear that i want boris
johnson to be a success i'll never
forget sitting next to him at dinner i
see it in my mind's eye now and he
started to talk about the condition and
the prosperity of the british people in
a way which was earnest and honest yeah
but if
you forgive me if i may interrupt boris
johnson i want to see
yeah forgive me though
boris johnson's idea of success may not
be exactly the same as yours and what
you seem to be saying here is that
success is not just a matter of winning
or getting through it or getting past
the next scandal it is also about what
you believe and how you behave so let me
ask you again
is boris johnson
still the kind of leader behaving in the
kind of way this uh displaying the kind
of morals that you feel
that the conservative party should still
support
i i think right now the prime minister
is in very great difficulty for the
reasons that you're indicating any
member of the public is going to rightly
demand that politicians not only comply
with the rules that they impose on other
people but that they're seen to comply
with their spirit and it's pretty
obvious now that that hasn't happened
and that is it that is a very bad
position to be in but let me be clear
trevor i've been down this road once
before viewers will know and i have
absolutely no intention this time around
of trying to remove a prime minister i
want to see boris turn this situation
around i want to see him rescue his
position i want to see him go on to be a
great success but he's not going to do
it by paying lip service to rules and
being in cautious about how his staff
behave and comply with them so you know
we didn't make him prime minister for
his meticulous attention to detail but
you know it is now time a time for
complete compliance with all rules
so you're clear he hasn't followed the
rules if he doesn't turn it around
within let's say a few months is it
going to be time for him to go
well trevor as i just said a moment ago
and i hope you will understand and your
viewers will understand i've been down
this road before and i'm determined not
to go down it again the reason that i'm
launching conservative or relaunching in
the new year conservative way forward is
because i think we need to create a
movement which says to boris and the
whole conservative party we want to live
in a society characterized by freedom
under the rule of law and personal
responsibility that's really what i'm
about
steve baker thank you very much indeed
you're very well so it has by
has by any estimation been a grim week
for the conservatives
and while labour's now got a consistent
lead in most polls it's still fairly
modest especially given the government's
travails
so why isn't the party making more
impact
well let's talk now to the labour
party's chair anna lisa
dodds good morning miss dodge
good morning um
first of all can we just be clear about
one thing uh this week in that vote on
uh the
covet strategy or covid tactics will you
be supporting the government's plan b
we've consistently put public health
over party politics so yes we will be
because we do need to protect public
health
it looks uh from what we've been reading
and indeed from what the secretary of
state
uh
said for education said this morning
talking about the extraordinary
exponential
growth of omicron that they will have to
go further will you support
a plan c
for example a further lockdown
well before any additional restrictions
should even be contemplated
we've got to see government urgently
taking a number of actions they should
be boosting the booster program we're
far behind where we need to be we
haven't seen those retired staff being
pulled back in those volunteers being
pulled back in for the booster like we
saw initially that's got to happen now
we need to see action on our schools
we've got less than half of the young
people who should have been vaccinated
by now actually having been vaccinated
the government doesn't seem to have any
uh plan for ventilation in schools all
they're saying to teachers is just open
the windows we'll try doing that in
december in lots of parts of our country
and of course they haven't fixed sick
pay either so there's a huge amount the
government must do must do urgently and
they must do that before they even
contemplate looking at any additional
restrictions this is very urgent now
so ventilation
uh a bigger drive for jabs for young
people and so on um you wouldn't go any
further at this point for example uh
extending vaccine passports
well we really need to get those other
measures in place because we know that
ultimately the vaccine is the strongest
barrier against this disease progressing
particularly with the omicron variant
there we've got to boost that booster
program that's going to be the strongest
defense
as you know trevor we've got those plans
that will be coming through around the
vaccination of nhs staff now actually we
want to see government working very very
hard as the welsh labour government has
done actually to make sure that nhs
staff have all the information about the
vaccine that there's a really strong
education and encouragement program
there that will drive up uptake if
ultimately that doesn't get us far
enough then we will not oppose a
passport scheme for those nhs
staff
but really government should be learning
from what's worked elsewhere and the
conservatives seem to be unwilling to do
that even though those education and
encouragement programs have been so
successful in labour on wales
there's one there's one estimate that
says that the nhs could lose
more than a hundred thousand staff
because of um mandatory vaccines uh you
would still
insist
that nhs staff had um were required to
have vaccinations at some point if
persuasion doesn't succeed
well the government has set out a
timetable of this beginning
in april so they've got a number of
months to really focus
on that education and encouragement and
you know this is not about remaking the
wheel as i said they've got a very good
example coming from cardiff with the
welsh labour government there where they
worked incredibly hard to get the
message out to combat this information
to make sure also the vaccination was
very very easy for nhs staff
to
take part in and that drove up those
levels you know they're significantly
higher amongst nhs staff in wales
compared to in england that ultimately
is what should be focused on but if it
doesn't get us as far as it needs to the
evidence that we've seen suggest that
mandatory vaccination for the nhs staff
may have to still be on the table in
april so we're not going to be arguing
against it for the sake of it
all right let's turn to the politics do
you
have confidence in the proposed or the
um ongoing cabinet secretary
investigation
into christmas parties and all of that
well i wish it was into christmas
parties and all of that because it isn't
an investigation that we'll be looking
into
all of the different parties that we've
seen evidence of no more well actually i
think they announced yesterday that they
were extending it
well i am encouraged if they genuinely
are because until recently the
suggestion was it would only cover
effectively one party but frankly of
course this is going even beyond number
10 because we have now heard that there
have been
social events which for example the
former education secretary took part in
so we've got to have full transparency
around that now the prime minister must
make sure that he is very open about
everything that he knows just a few days
ago the prime minister suggested he knew
nothing about any parties and then he
ordered an inquiry into one of them
that's a very strange set of affairs and
i think british people are really fed up
with all of this chaos with all of the
sleaze that's engulfing the prime
minister he's got to get a grip now and
our country's facing massive challenges
they need a government that actually is
adequate to face up to those challenges
rather than one that's just engulfed in
sleaze
are you um
is it a time for labor to be calling for
the prime minister to stand down at the
time of national crisis
wouldn't that be a non-partisan thing to
do
well obviously i'm a labour mp so from a
partisan point of view now i'm working
every day to try and get a new
government in place to try and get the
conservative government out but when it
comes to the prime minister's position
that's ultimately in the hands of the
conservative party and i do want them
yeah but come on come on
you've been telling us how important
this is for the country that you're
you're interested in the country rather
than party
we have a leader that your own leader
says is not fit for office and this is
not a party political thing we need a
prime minister who's going to lead us
through this crisis surely if you really
believed that you would be saying it is
time for boris johnson to resign and
allow somebody who can lead the country
effectively to take
the keys to number 10. so is it time for
boris johnson to stand down or not
we've been very very clear that he's
unfit for office but ultimately the
resignation of a conservative prime
minister is in the hands of the
conservative party not the hands of the
labour party and what we've been urging
week after week month after month okay
is for this conservative party to get a
grip because for as long as it doesn't
get a grip working families in our
country okay continue to pay the price
what analyzer dodds thank you very much
indeed
thank you
now the omicron variant was first
identified in south africa leading the
uk to impose a controversial travel ban
on several southern african countries it
means the uk is looking uh to data from
south africa to understand just how the
variant will behave and whether it will
lead to more hospitalizations and
possibly more restrictions therefore
here so let's uh hear from johannesburg
let's try and get a sense of what we can
learn from the real world data there and
to talk to the government covert advisor
there barry schube uh good morning again
professor shubh um
can you summarize for our viewers the
impact of omicron in your country thus
far how many infected how many
hospitalizations
and how many deaths
yeah good morning uh trevor
yeah i think it's been a kind of a mixed
bag in a way because basically on the
one hand we've had a very rapid rising
rate of infections in fact if you look
at the epidemic epidemic curve it's
almost vertical
so steep as it's going up in fact our
doubling time at the moment is about 1
to 1.5 days it's in other words every
one and a half days we're doubling in
numbers so it's it's rapidly increasing
that's on the one hand
on the other hand our hospitalization
rates have not been that high
and also within hospitalized uh within
hospitalized individuals uh it's only
about 15 percent i think is the latest
data we've got uh of those hospitalized
are actually either in icu or in high
care so it looks so far that the um
the clinical expression has been mild
but that could really be uh due to the
fact that immunity in the country is
high either from natural immunity or
past infection uh or from the uh from
vaccinations so that's the other so
that's the kind of positive side the
rate of transmission is the negative
side
and the one other negative that does
appear to be quite quite apparent
is that there's a lot of what we call
vaccine escape a lot of people that have
been fully vaccinated are still getting
infected but fortunately of that group
the great majority are mild so that's a
kind of a round
overall picture where we are at the
moment
that's very helpful um
the population south africa is
on average much younger than the
population here and our
cabinet minister secretary state for
education who i spoke to earlier in the
program
painted a picture of exponential growth
of omicron here which
at one level's pretty terrifying and he
said that even if it is milder as you
seem to be suggesting from the data in
south africa we could still end up with
a really large number of cases bearing
in mind
that uh we have you know many more older
people um is that something that we
ought to be alarmed about
you know trump don't want to give the
the kind of wrong impression that the uh
omicron is causing milder disease i
think what we're seeing there's a lot
more biology but that's i think because
of immunity uh it's very early days at
this stage and i don't think at this
stage we can be confident in saying
omicron is a milder variant we hope it's
going to be but i don't think we can say
and you know if you look at the virus
itself biologically today there's no
real evidence to suggest that it will be
milder so you make a very good point if
there's a higher proportion of older
individuals it may well not express
itself quite as much as we've seen quite
in the same way as you see in south
africa but i must what one thing i
should point out though is that we are
seeing more and more cases in younger
individuals in fact even in young
children as as young as two years of old
age we've seen quite some serious cases
so we need to kind of take that into the
balance as well
so would your advice to us be
don't get ahead of yourself treat this
as
being as serious potentially as delta or
any other variant we've encountered thus
far
i think we need to i think we need to
i think we must avoid trivializing it at
this stage we're still gathering
information we're hoping it's going to
be a time advice but we really cannot
say so at this stage so at the moment we
do need to treat it as seriously as
delta with all the kind of precautions
that we took for delta we can't let up
on that at the moment
have you got any thoughts or any idea
about how long before we'll get some
hard enough data to be able to make
you know proper sense of how serious
this thing really is
yeah we were all we are gathering data
in fact day by day week by week
um so i would guess that certainly in
the next couple of weeks which we should
have a much better uh perspective on the
virus
we must remember we've only had this
virus for about three or four weeks so i
still really early days in south africa
on the upward trajectory of our fourth
wave so we still need to kind of be
cautious hopefully three or four weeks
time we'll have a much better view of it
so we may know something by the new year
um
our government is saying and i heard it
again this morning from from our
minister
that uh
there is evidence that
the
booster jab uh has
a significant impact on the virulence of
uh omicron is that what you're seeing in
south africa
yes i think the booster certainly will
uh will have a significant effect you
know it's only relative that there is
vaccine escape so obviously the more we
stimulate the immune system we can kind
of get a higher level of immunity to
overcome this potential vaccine escape
in south africa we're not we haven't yet
we're not nearly as extensive
in boosting
as you are for example the united
kingdom so we wouldn't really be able to
kind of give data at this stage on that
professor thank you so much for your
information valuable and uh
fascinating as ever
thank you trevor thank you
well let's get a sense of what all that
could mean for the uk and just how bad
things could be in scotland where the
first minister says
there will be a tsunami of omicron cases
i'm joined now by the infectious
diseases expert professor debbie bogart
from the university of edinburgh good
morning professor bergart
um good morning
nicholas sturgeon's issued
this warning can you quantify that how
bad could it
be well i think the the data that we
have so far showed us clear um what
we've called already for 20 months or so
exponential growth of this new strain so
we have this train only for less than
two weeks and if you see that this trend
goes from one percent to two percent to
four percent to eight percent to sixteen
percent that clearly shows an
exponential growth and the interesting
thing here is that it takes all these
little steps um
every two to three days so if from today
this was friday so let's say today the
amount of uh cases that is explained by
omicron is about 30 percent um we can be
as high as 100 of all cases being
explained by omicron halfway this week
so it clearly shows that we we
can potentially face a tsunami of cases
so i fully agree with that
what is your view about this uh
discussion we've been having pretty much
all morning about whether um
the symptoms uh are gonna be milder out
of this uh variant or not
uh
is what you're seeing telling you
anything on that
topic
well i think everybody is is
saying we should be cautious and i agree
fully with that um we have a new variant
that we know
um
can infect people with
pre-existing immunity through a recent
infection uh by delta and also in fact
people that have been even double um
immunized
so but we assume that that immunity that
they have will protect them
in part against uh severe disease but
also with delta we've seen we still have
quite a significant amount of people in
in hospital i think we're about 6000
cases at the moment isn't it in hospital
in in the entire uk
so even if omicron would be slightly
milder if this exponential growth keeps
on continuing because a much larger
proportion of the population is
susceptible we can ultimately face quite
an overwhelming number of cases anyway
in the hospital so yeah the good news is
we might be either because the strain is
perhaps
causing milder uh illness or less severe
cases and we might be partially
protected by our pre-existing immunity
if the doubling time and the number of
cases keep on continuing like they're
doing now we might still reach
very large numbers and even if a small
proportion of those get
um require hospitalizations
we might get quickly overwhelmed and i
agree that we need to um see how this
all pans out in the coming weeks but i
don't think that if we really want to be
ahead of the game we have weeks to sit
down and wait to see what's happening so
we
probably need to
act pretty fast to be ahead of the game
so is it your view that what we need to
do is to behave as though
the nhs is likely to be overwhelmed by
the combination of uh existing delta uh
cases plus what might happen
out of omicron and if we're lucky we
won't have that but that we have to now
behave as though that's the case
yeah exactly i think everybody had the
number of one million cases that could
potentially our theory be reached
by christmas and um i think we all can
feel that that's way too much and would
way overwhelm the system um let alone um
have a lot of people being put into
isolation not being able to to celebrate
christmas
we have already measures in place we
have already um immunity in place so we
need to up our game i think
um so i think the first thing we we have
that we didn't have a year ago are the
vaccines so i would
um ask everyone either if you had zero
one or two vaccines to try to quickly
get the next vaccine because if as a
community we can up our community
immunity we hopefully can push that
virus a bit down and slow it down
out of that rapid exponential growth
and the other thing is i i you know the
measures in scotland is now that if you
have a case in in in a household that
you need to self-isolate as a household
and although i agree um people might not
like that it's the best thing to do
over the last days data came from
england showing that household
transmission of this strain is three
times as high as from delta so that
means you can't you can't um
um let this
this go or take that chances so it's
definitely a measure that hopefully
helps to reduce this threat
so you so you would you would argue for
slightly tougher measures would you uh
also
support the vaccination of primary
school children now
yeah and there are several countries
already that do immunize primary school
children it's definitely a discussion
that we hear um
too little
um it's um the chain is as weak as the
weakest link i would say from an
immunity uh perspective and we still
have many children that have no
protection um by vaccination so we have
a safe vaccine and i think it would be
wise to really quickly consider uh
whether parents have the choice to get
their children from the age of five up
immunized but also the children 12 up
that had only one vaccine or none at all
yet i would um actually advise to go and
get that um shot the first or the second
and everybody who already got one or two
shots to get the second or the third and
otherwise i think we really need to up
our again with the measures we already
have think about masking i really think
everybody should
really
follow
that advice and in crowded places where
you can't keep distance mask up not only
over the mouth but also over the nose
and preferably very well fitting
mask and if it's crowded you can't keep
your distance uh you could even consider
a a higher rate mask in ffp2 as they
call it or even double mask because we
really anticipate this will help
just very briefly uh professor berg if i
may just ask you very briefly uh you may
have heard my interview our interview
with um
steve baker mp earlier on and he
essentially said that we have to trust
people we have to give people freedom
that the question of restrictions is
really a moral one how does a scientist
respond to that
yeah as a scientist and a doctor i know
that people um like to have a choice but
also want to be well informed and want
to be able to weigh
their decisions based on the facts and i
think what we can do is show the fact
show how significant this is how quickly
this can get out of hand and ask them to
really work with us to try to limit the
spread it's not only and a general um
uh benefit but also in people's
individual benefits because we want to
celebrate christmas after all isn't it
oh
okay professor pogba i'm sorry to stop
you but uh we did have to move on but
thank you so much for your time this
morning
you're welcome have a good day
you too now covid has had a huge impact
on the life chances of young people
education work family it means millions
have missed out and it seems those in
the north of the country have been
particularly affected
um a disturbing port by my next guest
shows that it could affect those young
people throughout their lives and i'm
joined now by professor kate pickett of
york university good morning professor
what were you trying to discover with
the work that you did here
well what we were trying to do
was not so much discover but synthesize
like put together all of the evidence
about how children in the north were
disadvantaged compared to their peers in
the south and the rest of england before
covert but also to look at the
disproportionate impact that covid has
had
on children in the north so there's not
a lot in this report that's brand new i
mean a lot of us have known much of this
evidence before but it's the first time
it's all been put together
and together it makes a really
disturbing picture
so what what are the headlines on that
picture what what did uh putting the
evidence together tell you that um
you know we ought to be concerned about
well it highlights how disadvantaged
children in the north are in terms of
their mental health their physical
health their education their life
chances even before covid and how
disproportionately affected by the
pandemic they have been so they've
missed more schooling their mental
health has been worse affected their
physical activity levels are lower and
we've also been able to put a cost on
this so we can see that unless we
mitigate against that extra damage that
extra impact
we will see a scar across the life
chances of those children and that will
affect their lifelong productivity and
the productivity of the north of england
in general so if we want to really you
know do the best for our economy for
leveling up and for individual children
then we need to invest where it's needed
most
so to be clear on this uh graph that
we're seeing just uh
to make sure i understand it properly
what we're saying what you're saying is
that in lifetime earnings
children at school now can expect to see
something like 12 and a half thousand uh
a penalty if you like because penalty
yes
exactly
okay um
you also had some date i think about the
number of months lost uh if you like in
in learning uh advance
that's right so children in the north of
england experienced more restrictions
you know more months of restrictions
than children elsewhere and that
affected their learning and so we find
that they've lost four to five months
more of maths literacy learning than
children elsewhere in england so that
that's a really big loss
what you if you had your your your way
uh okay pick it um what would you do to
help those children catch up what can
you give me a magic wand okay if you're
giving me a magic wand i would ask the
government to put children and families
at the heart of the leveling up agenda
and target their investment where it's
needed the most to the most deprived
areas and to the areas most affected by
the pandemic
and to invest in early childhood and
they could do things so easily they
could increase child benefit top up the
child aspect of the universal credit
child tax credits um fund family centers
even more than they promised to do in
the budget so it's just a matter of
directing
their investment to the places that need
it the most
let's stick with the uh sky news magic
one for a moment and you've got it last
week we were
in
a town called ghoul on the humber which
is exactly one of the kinds of places
that i think people will be talking
about when they're talking about
leveling up in in practice
what you've just said how would that
make a difference for
a family
in ghoul which currently
maybe somebody's lost their job where
they uh feel that
in jargon they've been left behind what
would they see
that would be different that would help
to close this
gap that you've described
well we know that all parents want to do
the best for their children and if
you're feeling that your children's life
chances are being hampered by poverty
um by poor schools by
lack of services that's incredibly
stressful and so i think even um small
amounts of investment into into families
livelihoods can really reduce
stress for parents can really impact
things like food security housing
security enabling families to have
the time and the care for their children
and to be able to to nurture them in the
ways that they would most wish to
so
fairly small amounts for families can
make a big difference
and the kinds of investment that we're
asking for the kinds of recommendations
that we're making in this report really
could tip the balance between children
having the best start in life or
children being
in families where the chronic stress of
poverty is really affecting everybody's
life chances and well-being
the major government player here is uh
the new relatively new secretary of
state for leveling up michael gove um
have you sent the report to him and what
would be your expectation of his
response
our report is going to all relevant
ministers and mps and we already know
that there's cross-party support for for
doing something about the
recommendations in this report i would
ask him to come and talk to us
and i would ask him to make sure that
children and families at the heart of
leveling up
okay well next time he's uh here with us
on sunday morning i'll ask him uh how he
responds to all of that uh kate thank
you very much indeed for your time this
morning thanks for having me
well uh that is as much as we've got
time for this morning it is without
doubt going to be a bumpy ride into
christmas for uh the government and for
politics in general we thought we would
um not be here next week but i can tell
you happy days we will be back next
sunday the moment sam coats and the take
[Music]